please say well why don't you tell me in
tones described below angry well why
don't you tell me
sad well why don't you tell
me annoyed at yourself because you
forgot to buy paper towels at the
grocery store for the second time in a
week well why don't you tell me
curious why don't you tell me pissy well
why don't you tell me overly friendly
well why don't you tell me explaining
the concept of Death to Your Child for
the first time
well why don't you tell me welcoming a
family of four to your restaurant well
why don't you tell me a morning Zoo host
giving a prize to a listener from
Minneapolis because they were the 97th
caller to use the phrase the pays which
is well why don't you tell me
uhuh well why don't you tell me